there's two types of baby mamas ones
that understand they took an L they
understand dating is harder they're not
on government assistance they're just
like you know what I'm a baby mama I
took that L I know is gonna be
harder for me but there's still a little
delusional as in they still have hope
even when for a lot of them it's over
these are baby mamas are usually a bit
better than the second type of baby
Mama's like I put it some of them are in
the church they're like reformed but
they still don't think they're a modern
woman because they're like I'm not like
those baby mamas well well Teresa kinda
are you are but you aren't okay